salut aujourd'hui je suis avec mon pote
reynald zapata c'est monsieur zapata et
sa patte ait fait quoi dans la vie
il peint ils partent très vite et du
coup tu es un street fighter mais en
même temps tu connaissais déjà réponse
est oui et bien souvent au plateau les
hallucinations collectives et autres
illusions fantastique que je fais au
grand point virgule prochaine si le 22
février il y en a eu 28 mars où tu seras
la deux a commenté
et à chaque fois je demande au public de
me donner un thème ou une personnalité
ou quelque chose et reynald doit le
peindre le plus rapidement possible une
fois ça durait deux heures on n'a pas
reconnu à la fin c'était un moment très
gênant du coup comme des peintres j'ai
pensé à essayer de te faire faire un
petit dessert alors voici l'idée tu vas
prendre ce calepin tu fais tu fais un
petit dessin dessus ouais un truc simple
je suis pas contre moi tu arraches la
feuille qui referme le carnet et tu me
redonne tout ça ça marche ça marche
gérant chez lafarge la garderie lagarde
pour toi bien dans une poche ne faut pas
que je le vois donc peut-être tourne toi
et puis moi je les regarde pendant ce
temps la chanson dessin un dessin pas un
truc trop compliqué d'accord d'accord on
entend dès qu'elles sont à voir et pour
garder le mental bugs et utah bonne à
cette chaîne youtube sinon j'ai
l'impression d'être tout seul et qu'il
ya que ma mère qui regarde oui je sais
pas si vous le saviez vous pouvez vous
abonner en cliquant sur le petit logo
que je mets dans la vidéo définissez sa
voile à l'école y faire d'arromanches et
d'arracher la feuille terre ferme et de
carnets tous voila on faire marche
arrière
suspense parce que j'ai pas encore
expliquer ce que j'ai essayé de faire
super que je vais essayer de faire c'est
de retrouver le maximum d'éléments de
ton dessin je vous promets pas de
retrouver le dessin fait un maximum
d'éléments ma première question j'ai une
question c'est est-ce que c'est un objet
non donc c'est pas quelque chose que
physiquement
affable et pas noire comme quoi tu es un
peintre quand je fais ce genre
d'expérience sur quelqu'un à chaque fois
et dessiner un objet quelque chose du
quotidien et ça m'aide beaucoup pour le
retrouver victoire c'est plus un stade
ça dommage
est ce que tu peux tu imaginer que ton
dessin est ici juste ici est que avec
mon doigt je joue avec les formes qui
est à faire ou alors c'est de trouver
des choses dernière avec l'arrondi c'est
ça ouais ok ça je le mets au budget j'ai
des pistes d'idées je voulais dessiner
et alors ce qui est cool c'est que vous
allez pouvoir juste voir en même temps
que moi ce que je dessine
ça c'est rigolo
moi j'ai une espèce d'arrondi ici donc
fait dessiner la petite confirmation ou
infirmation à ce que jusqu'ici savoir
s'il aimerait juste sa jalousie ok donc
c'est une très bonne piste pour moi m'a
dit c'est plein d'objets dont je crois
que j'aille sur le côté des verts des
envies des choses comme ça des
champignons c'est très très bien je vais
essayer d'aller jusqu'au dessin à ma
manière et je vais essayer un truc comme
ça mais c'est tellement de dire est que
je fais donc je me suis pas plus que
nous que l'on se rassure à toute la page
d'accueil
voici ce que j'ai dessiné ce qu'on peut
comparer avec ton dessin voyez-vous là
c'est quand même la tête je sais que
j'ai juste un oui bah ouais voilà à quoi
que on est quand même pas mal quoi
conclure c'est une danseuse que j'ai
fait signe dans cet enfer pendant six
mois le retour à la vie
vous voyez que même en une seconde il
fuit depuis ce que moi et c'est beaucoup
plus joli que moi merci moi pas tu as et
marca du match nul entre ses doigts vers
le tchad ou au chaud le sign up savent
même pas combien sabrosa bas maintenant
ça vaut cher 100 nature ça vaut rien
avec ça je répète on a acheté un
carambar jeter xing voilà et avec ça tu
achètes la serviette pour essuyer à près
de 40 bars super retrouver zapata et
toutes ses créations il en poste souvent
il fait aussi du street art plein de
choses sur twitter @ zapata printer
rejoignez-les vraiment c'est ta petite
bouffée de plaisir au quotidien alors
nous tous à cette chaîne youtube suis
monsieur zapata twitter demain 17h pour
le prochain mentale blog ciao